the idea was this was going to be the
Bell Labs memo that never was it would
never be released so said the lawyers
because it was too sensitive for 33
years this was all that we had and I
suppose in modern parlance it became a
sort of reverse engineering jailbreak as
you might say many of you know far
better than I do already about the two
big heroes of Dennis Ritchie and Ken
Thompson there's a third person we're
going to bring in today and the one if
you like it Bell Labs that I know really
really well for more than 30 years now
that of course is Brian Kernighan and I
think if only from this book here those
who haven't heard of him they suddenly
say oh yes probably the third best known
person in the UNIX finland's after
Denison ken one of the suspects you
recognized straight away as me the one
at the far right is my colleague Steve
who features later on in this story and
the person in the middle there the
bearded gentleman is Brian Brian
Kernighan that's taken about three years
ago when we visited Brian and it's in a
coffee shop just off the main campus of
Princeton University when you look to
the version 7 UNIX manual the thing that
really struck you was it at Bell Labs
they not only could afford pdp-11 'zv
axes and all sorts of stuff but they
could afford typesetters it's hard to
realize nowadays what that meant laser
printers had not been invented at best
if you were lucky you could get a good
if you like dot matrix printer effect
but actually getting x roman curia Zapf
Chancery Helvetica Arial whatever turns
you on no that was not in the compass of
normal mortals because it cost a heck of
a lot of money so what we're going to
take a look at today is how and why Bell
Labs had typesetters what they did with
them and how they really were
instrumental in making typesetting
democratic for the rest of
it was very early work but it was
massively influential and one of the
people who led the charge on that
because he did a lot of the work himself
and he was kind of informally the leader
of the typesetting software effort at
Bell Labs was Brian Brian Kernighan Bell
Labs choice of third-generation
typesetter would only cost fifty
thousand dollars in 1979 money which is
just horrendous to think of by
comparison you could easily buy a house
you could easily buy a house for $50,000
a really very good one I would think
yeah
they look long and hard what was
available and decided that they would go
with Mergen tyler and at this machine UK
design is called the liner tronic 202
this was the one step before laser
printers came on the scene naked mini -
floppy disk drives control console paper
tape here is a board from the naked mini
and it shows you very definitely how
solidly mini computer the computational
facilities were and there's all of the
boards that comprise the naked mini
receptor cassette fed from bromide paper
at the back hidden under their high-res
cathode ray tube 972 dots to the H and
shaped a bit like a letterbox in many
ways you exposed the bromide paper in
bands and when you finish doing the
current band you mechanically move the
bromide away from it at huge cost from
either liner type or some other supplier
you bought a bromide or film processor
you took along your cassette you fed it
in to the end of this thing which have
three separate tanks smelly developer
with whether yes I can smell it even now
wash water in the middle after the
developing was done of the image and
then of course fixer at the end and the
fixer smoke the worst of all czar sort
of faintly acidic smell about it then it
came out at the end it probably had
another one
at the end and then it went through a
dryer or your hyung is up to dry and
then finally you've got your beautiful
bromide output which you could slice up
and make it into page sized slices what
you then did with it was if you just
wanted to send a proof of what it types
it out all your friends there were of
course Xerox and other photocopies
around you could photocopy the bromide
output but if you wanted really high
quality and you were doing a long print
run what you would have to do at this
generation was to send your photographic
output off to a plate maker that would
convert your photograph into an offset
printer metal plate the idea is you have
a plate on a cylindrical drum which
rolls round and round at very high speed
and can print off tens of thousands of
copies of things like newspapers or
whatever so that's basically the
technology behind third-generation
cathode ray tube driven typesetters and
as far as Bell Labs are concerned it
just changed everything because with the
ability to be imaging onto a cathode ray
tube you could not just have the ability
to use preset fonts like in earlier
generations you know letter S is
magnified various size you got all of
that but you had the ability to draw
lines you could do primitive line
graphics and certainly Brian and others
at Bell Labs really really wanted to do
that they could see the potential
straightaway but in terms of getting the
full value out of this what they naively
perhaps thought shouldn't be too much
trouble was to ask Mergenthaler very
nicely if they would let them have the
spec for how the digital fonts were held
on floppy disks why send Mergenthaler
because we want to create our own lace
well I gather the roof Ellen a total
total total disbelief
why would you want to do that you know
this isn't a machine for amateurs one
example of the fonts that they wanted
was a set of chess pieces this is the
time to bring in one of our other heroes
Ken Thompson already mentioned in the
previous unix video he was part of
Brian's team for commissioning the 202
typesetter it was led by Brian himself
of course and crucially they also had a
hardware man called Joe Condon very
talented hardware engineer some of you
will know that Joe Kannan and Ken
Thompson were famous just before this
era mid seventies of creating the Bell
chess machine ken was there a sort of
ultimate software guru who was mad keen
to create his own chess font and also
very happy to get deep into the line of
Tron as deep was needed Mergenthaler
just said I'm sorry gentlemen it's a
flat no we are not going to reveal to
you how our fonts are done yeah yeah we
thoroughly accept your bell labs you
know you have enough hassle from
antitrust legislation we know you are
not going to set yourself up as rivals
you're not going to become just a font
shop and you know do cheaper fonts now
as we do-- we accept it but nevertheless
there was a feeling rightly I think in
Mergenthaler that this was like opening
Pandora's box even though these three
talented chaps at Bell Labs were quite
prepared to sign every nondisclosure
agreement going
the answer was firmly no absolutely no
so they basically said well we're going
to do it anyway and I suppose in modern
parlance it became a sort of reverse
engineering jailbreak as you might say
the with the wisdom former guitar which
you'll never do it
you know our fonts are not deliberately
encrypted but they are so compressed and
so compact and in such such an obscure
format you will not succeed in
deciphering how we do it and why we do
it to which I think Brian probably
muttered under his breath what you don't
know is I've got a secret weapon
and it's not a piece of hardware it's
called Ken Thompson
it took can with some help from Brian
who always under plays his own role in
this basically between two and three
weeks to get the overall idea of how it
all worked it took about six weeks for
total knowledge but that included
complete knowledge of exactly what the
resolution was of that CRT the timings
everything
you just wouldn't wanted a more talented
team to prove that this could be done
they created their own fonts
ken did his chest fun there were no
chess fonts were at the time there's
hundreds of them now an email he sent to
me said well I just want to do something
really quickly because I wanted to
publish books and I wanted a proper
chess font zaps Palatino but there is
Ken Thompson's chess font in action the
whole of this book all done on the
Linotype 202 so that is one of the
rationales for wanting to be able to do
your own fonts Brian and I have
traditionally referred to this work that
he did as the vacation project right
because it was in the vacation period in
the middle of 1979 that they spent their
six weeks reverse-engineering the 202
but when it came to the turn of 1980
Brian was absolutely adamant that he
wanted to write a memo about not the
fine details of Howard's had been done
but just the overall picture saying we
did it this is what we can now do isn't
it wonderful
not in any way to be an T Mergenthaler
although their version of the 202 was
very very unreliable as you'll be able
to read in this memo we'll try and set
up some web pointers for you as part of
this video so you can read it for
yourself but he just wanted to tell the
story Mergenthaler got wind of it and
basically said no absolutely no got in
touch with Bell Labs lawyers and to cut
a long story short it was suppressed the
idea was that this was going to be the
Bell Labs memo that never was it would
never be released so said the lawyers
because it was too sensitive but it was
with hindsight a real point to the
future when fonts would be
commonplace within the laser printer era
and so on for 33 years this was all that
we had as the hardcopy evidence of the
technical memorandum the thing I'm
kicking myself for now is that I didn't
actually keep any bromide I've got lots
of other bits and pieces here I've got
font books for the supplied with the
Linotype 202 but I didn't actually keep
any proper bromide and nor it would seem
did Brian because here this isn't the
bromide it's an nth-order photocopy of
the bromide off the 202 and you can see
what's happened
every photocopying process adds so many
percent the apparent boldness bits have
got chopped off and truncated off the
bottom filing marks here however as you
turn over you can begin to see just what
was turning them on about the abilities
of the 202
for the first time using Brian's pick
preprocessor they could draw a line
diagram of how it worked on the 202
little cathode ray tube 16 bit naked
mini driving it floppy disk character
definitions on integrated line diagram
out proof not stuff that you had to have
drawn by an artist and pasted in and
made a place of or whatever afterwards
the governing organization if you like
for what's left of Bell Labs is now
called alcatel-lucent so I suggested to
Brian and a good mutual friend chuck
Bigelow typographer said yeah yeah you
ought you guys ought to do this I said
why don't we ask the powers-that-be for
permission is it's not sensitive anymore
33 years after the event please can we
recreate the vacation memo as we came to
call it the really big plus point of
course was that it was typeset in this
type SATA version of that original run
off program tear off the typesetter
version or rough tear off can be
equipped with macros to help you do the
layout and all this sort of thing anyway
to my amazement I've got a more
authentic
an ancient set of SuperDuper tear-off
macros for doing Bell Labs memos than
even Brian had so we were able with a
fair bit of effort to recreate the memo
at the sort of quality but would
certainly been obtainable from the 202
if only we'd hung on to the bromides
yeah but we didn't
however this of course has all been done
via PostScript and PDF and modern
technologies but we're trying as hard as
we possibly can to still retain the look
and feel of what it would have looked
like at best quality coming off the
electronic to route to one of the best
ways to show what we were up against and
when we succeeded or not was to show an
a/b comparison here is the original memo
not as a bromide as it should have been
but as I sort of n thought a photocopy
of it
first of all finished off properly at
the bottom don't forget we didn't have
the appearance of this we didn't save
the bromide but what we did have was the
tear off source code yeah Brian had
saved that thank heavens we would have
been struggling without that although in
the end we could have rebuilt it with
optical character recognition and lap
but he saved the tear off so instead of
running tear off through a back-end to
the - OH - we never-- and tear off to
another back-end out to PostScript in
PDF so here we go
nice and clean knowing bleed straight
off a good quality laser printer Oh
Bell Labs logo revived as a font
character all over again and even shrunk
down it says here the most obvious
special character we use is the Bell
System logo I'm jumping ahead now the
thing that Brian was trying to get
across in this memo was this in this era
you mustn't imagine that the 202 and its
characters were able to do splines and
arcs and complex curves no they couldn't
I mean quite apart for anything else
there wasn't the process of power to be
able to do the computer graphics
necessary to turn those into dots on the
CRT fast enough know what you had to do
was to simplify and make all your
characters be lots and lot
small line segments so these diagrams
here as you can see I put little arrows
on not really part of the character just
to emphasize to you this is where each
line segment begins and ends so that
Helvetica font letter e is a bunch of
straight lines and there were severe
limits on how many you could have at
most of straight lines in any one
character but it worked well enough so
long as you didn't take your character
size above about an inch at most and
then you began to be able to see the
straight line approximation is the naked
mini was going flat out and even then it
could just about cope with characters
done as lots of straight lines
it certainly could not cope with arcs
and splines okay so let's just summarize
the two big challenges that we faced in
recreating this vacation memo fonts like
Times Roman Helvetica Korea if there
there are no problem they existed on the
202 but they've been brought forward
into the PostScript and TrueType modern
fonts era those are easy to get hold of
the harder bits here was what we had to
recreate because they just didn't exist
except on the 202 the first time most
obvious is Ken's chess phone so starting
from first principles again I created a
few shapes using Brian's pick program
and handed them over to my colleague
Steve whose photograph you've already
seen Steve Bagley we also discovered by
the by in doing this that Ken Thompson
faced with the problems of fonts on the
202 where individual character shouldn't
get too complex you'll never guess how
he did something like a porn here on a
shiny black background the overall
character would have been too
complicated so what he did was he
created extra characters which was the
cutout shape at the back partly shaded
and then dropped the pawn shape on top
of them as a zero width character so
it's a super position we were authentic
we did that in our replica the other
thing which caused me many sleepless
nights is that the liner Tron font for
doing program printouts courier if you
like
was called printout heaven knows why
ladder type Mergenthaler didn't just do
courier but they didn't next thing to do
is to phone up the font shop in
Cheltenham and say print out on the tour
- it's been turned into PostScript
hasn't it by some money for some reason
no comes back a reply
it was 202 only we never converted that
one so decided to recreate it in
conjunction with my friend Chuck Bigelow
type designer we had a look at this
print out font in the liner type fonts
book Chuck took one look at that he said
that's come from a variable width
typewriter font something like excelsior
but they've hacked it about to make it a
fixed pitch font like courier and it's
quite right if you look at the tiny
details you can see it's Excelsior
messed about with so with the sinking
heart I started off with excelsior I
spent I'm not exaggerating 120 hours
chopping stems chopping down serifs
resizing placing in fixed with carrot
positions trying all the current as I
could to get them to look right it's not
bad I'm still not happy with it at all
but if somebody was a revelation to me
as to just how incredibly
labor-intensive type design is but for
the sake of authenticity and when you
look inside the vacation memo you will
see Brian wrote a heartfelt letter to
Mergenthaler
about the lack of reliability of their
202 and he wrote it in the print out
font so I wanted it to look right so
that just about summarizes I think the
big two challenges that we had to
overcome and I think we're now just
about completely succeeded slight
restoring pictures you don't want to
over restore you want to use exactly the
original materials and do it just right
but overall I'm pretty happy I don't
think we did too badly
all of your characters in the current
font available as photographic images
what you've now got to do is to transfer
the photographic image of the capital
letter S shall we say from the strip
onto a piece of photosensitive paper you
put this down into a thing that looks
like a top-loading washing machine in
the laundry